el primer presidente en la historia en
ser sometido a un segundo impeachment y
en esta votación los sí son 232 los none
son 197 se adopta la resolución radial
del sin receta de la cámara de
representantes aprobó que el presidente
saliente se ha sometido nuevamente a un
juicio político en el senado está
acusado de haber incitado a la
insurrección después de que centenares
de sus seguidores irrumpieron
violentamente en el capitolio el 6 de
enero en febrero de 2020 trump fue
absuelto en el primer impeachment pero
esta vez el proceso tiene apoyos incluso
entre algunos republicanos en el senado
se necesitará que al menos 17
republicanos voten en contra de trump
para alcanzar la mayoría de dos tercios
necesaria para destituirlo además el
tiempo juega en contra ya que el senado
no se reunirá hasta el 19 de enero un
día antes de que joe biden tome posesión
como presidente de eeuu
eso significa que probablemente tro amp
ya no será presidente cuando el senado
lo procese pero de ser condenado el
legislativo todavía podrá impedir que se
vuelva a presentar a futuras elecciones
con los votos de una mayoría simple
trump publicó un vídeo en las cuentas
oficiales del gobierno con un nuevo tono
conciliador
y quiero ser claro condeno
inequívocamente la violencia que vimos
la semana pasada la violencia y el
vandalismo no tienen lugar en nuestro
país ni en nuestro movimiento
no dijo ni una palabra sobre el juicio
político pero se esforzó en desligarse
de todo lo que se parezca a una
incitación a la insurrección